- C'est un nouveau départ pour
Mohammad, sa femme et leurs deux
fils de 18 et 21 ans.
Ils sont arrivés d'Afghanistan
le 11 août à Toronto.
Radio-Canada accepte de ne pas
dévoiler son nom complet
pour des raison de sécurité.
"C'était très occupé pendant la
quarantaine", dit-il. "On avait
des rendez-vous sur Zoom pour
nous expliquer comment allait
se passer notre installation,
les papiers administratifs
à remplir, notre numéro
d'assurance sociale,
comment nous déplacer."
Après sa quarantaine, il a
choisi de s'installer à Thunder
Bay, car c'est ici que vit
son ami et ancien patron.
Comme Mohammad, quelque 500
Afghans ont déjà été relogés
dans des collectivités
ontariennes, selon Ottawa.
Et ils sont prêts à commencer
une nouvelle vie.
"On a reçu notre résidence
permanente, on prend des cours
d'anglais."
À London, 36 Afghans ont été
accueillis dans la communauté.
VALERIAN MAROCHKO, directeur,
London Cross Cultural Learner
- Ce sont des gens qui ont
travaillé pour l'Ambassade
du Canada, comme des interprètes
pour les Forces armées. Ce sont
des gens prêts à entrer
dans le milieu du travail.
- Et c'est le défi qui attend
ces nouveaux arrivants :
trouver un logement,
un travail, mais aussi surmonter
leurs traumatismes.
"J'ai perdu mon plus jeune
fils, mon père, un cousin.
Au total, six membres de ma
famille sont morts lorsque
les talibans ont attaqué
ma maison", raconte Mohammad,
qui vivait dans un village de la
province de Kandahar.
Le soutien mental est vital,
rapporte aussi Nooria Kamran.
Avec son organisme "Enfants sans
frontière", elle apporte
vêtements, jouets et produits
essentiels à quelque 350 Afghans
en quarantaine près de Toronto.
Parmi eux, de nombreux enfants,
parfois orphelins.
"Hier, un enfant de 6 ans
en détresse psychologique a été
envoyé à l'hôpital",
raconte-t-elle.
Ils sont traumatisés, mais ont
de l'espoir, selon elle.
Un espoir et des rêves qu'on
peut lire dans le regard
et les mots de Mohammad.
"Nous sommes prêts à étudier
fort et travailler pour que
nos rêves se réalisent
dans notre nouveau pays."
Ici Camille Feireisen,